vous avez le faire maintenant pour me
donner les pieds tout seul c'est orange
exactement comme ça
maintenant comme ça
à
je veux pas qu avait enlevé l'achète
j'avais juste un type on m'avait enlevé
quelque chose ne savais pas ce que
c'était ok j'ai fait c'était bizarre
il est l'un des meilleurs français en
activité une crotta sa particularité
ce magicien comédien un peu clown aussi
il faut le dire
n'hésite pas à faire participer le
public c'est même sa principale
signature
[Applaudissements]
c'est très drôle en fait ça m'a fait
rire alors j'avais le trac en plus
j'avais l'impression de tremblay un peu
c'est super c'est impressionnant
justement le spectacle qui nous a
vraiment plu
et puis en plus nos copains se montent
sur scène donc non non c'est vraiment
chouette vraiment sympa bien sûr une
protéine comme les autres il a ses
numéros favoris parmi eux celui des
pigeons ce tour de passe-passe lui a été
transmis par pierre bras bâ décédé il ya
deux ans un numéro jouer dans 47 pays
dans le monde depuis plus de 60 ans
c'est avec plaisir que je joue ce numéro
depuis six ans maintenant
et là il ya un public d'enfants
extraordinaire les réactions sont
vraiment fantastique parce que c'est un
univers très féerique et enchanteur et
on est dans les racines dans la
tradition de notre patron le maître de
la magie moderne qu'est robert houdin ce
stage de la toussaint la maison de la
magie de blois et le rendez vous le plus
important de l'année pour l'équipe de
france dans la catégorie manipulation la
france fait partie des trois meilleures
nations au monde avec les pays bas et la
corée du sud
l'équipe composée de huit magicien
défendra ses chances à nouveau en
juillet prochain lors des championnats
d'europe en espagne
[Applaudissements]